hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played yesterday in
jannie pomnisch's banter blitz session
on chess24 a lot of you have uh
been requesting jan's games as he's the
challenger to magnus carlsen in their
world chess championship match in
november
and i decided to show you this one uh
it's it's a fun blitz game it
features an opening that you might try
and use in your own blitz games online
so do do try that as well
uh but we are of course uh going to
check out some some more classical games
uh
worry not uh so that being said uh let's
check out
this game and see what happened so he's
facing math man he's an international
master
uh and that's all that we know about him
uh hence the hoodie hope you guys are
wearing one as well
uh now let's check it out so nipple with
the white pieces opens with
d4 we have knight to f6 knight to c3 and
now
d5 with bishop to f4 and now
bishop to f5 going for us symmetrical uh
developing
uh moves uh ended now the immediate
knight to b5 going for the c7 pawn
and already black has only one move here
knight to a6 he has to defend the pawn
we have e3 by nipple and now e6 you
could also just
chase away the knight with c6 but no one
ever plays this because after the night
moves yes you can bring this knight back
into the game
uh but uh where where where is this
knight even going it doesn't really
have any good squares or any uh well
prospects uh for for
the future of the game so instead after
e3
uh we have e6 and now knights to f3 just
continuing development bishop to e7 and
now there are some moves that have been
played here nipple goes knights to e5
and this is now a new move in the
position already as of move seven
uh is that we have a completely new game
uh so here
uh we have castles uh castles is maybe a
bit premature here
uh a move uh you might consider or but
it's hard to figure what to play here
for black
a move you might consider something like
knight b4 going after the c2 pawn
doesn't really work because there's this
very nasty knight captures on c7 with
check and now black is well without a
good move he has to play king to f8
uh because if you capture the knight
then you get bishop to b5 check and now
nothing really works for you if you
block with the knight
then knight captures and opens up a
discovery towards the queen so you can't
capture back
and if you don't uh block if you go king
to f8 then we can just play knight g6
check and pick up the black queen so
there's also that
let's say h captures bishop captures on
c7 so instead after this knight to e5
move black decided to castle
but now white gets a very nice
initiative going
by immediately jumping in with g4
so the bishop is under attack the pawn
is defended by the queen and by the
knight
we have to move the bishop back and now
h4 already threatening uh
to trap this bishop with a h5 and f3
so here h6 we have to make room for the
bishop and then now comes well you could
continue with the g5 pushing the pawns
knight captures on g6 and here in nepal
does kind of ruin black's king side we
have f captures in g6 and now
bishop to d3 going after this undefended
g6 pawn
so knight to the e4 preventing this and
now the immediate the g5
saying that uh if you capture here and
open up my h file that's gonna be
really bad for you because for example
captures captures and captures we can
just play queen to g4
and not a lot for uh for black to do
here for example if you capture we're
just going to capture here
we're going to castle maybe bring the
other rook into the game uh not
not a lot of fun we're going to play f3
kick away this knight win the spawn
control these squares maybe even
easily check me to the the black king a
lot can happen here
so instead after this g5 move uh mathman
decides to close the position
and now knight back to c3 saying that i
really want you to move this knight so i
can pick up this pawn
but here matman says okay bishop to b4
now
i'm threatening to win material here uh
but nipple just
nicely uh gets out of the way with king
to f1
and this is one of the uh nicer ways to
to utilize this move and it's not a uh
rarely played move it's
actually played very often when white
goes for the for the
similar ideas like maybe for in the
london system you're just gonna play
king f1 push
push the king side pawns and try and win
the game quickly
but okay here we have bishop captures b
captures and now you could go for the
c3 pawn but it seems that uh
uh he he decides against it because if
you if you go for this
then you get something like queen e1
attack the knight and now if the knight
goes back now you just kick it away with
f3 and then you're going to win the
spawn
or black has to go for some e5 ideas
which
will will not end all that well so
instead after b
captures on c3 we have the immediate e5
and now uh what do you play here well d
captures an e5 and now
uh why does spawn sacrifice well by
removing the pawn from d4
you've uh well you won the c5 square for
your knight so here
knight to c5 this is how you get the
knight back into the game
king to g2 and now comes knight
to e6 again knight captures and c3 is a
possibility but the black decides
against it
knight to e6 and now as the bishop is
under attack twice
bishop to g3 we have queen to e7
and now finally f3 kicking away this
knight we have
rook 8 to d8 trying to trick nipple
because if the knight is captured then
we can just capture with the pawn and
then the bishop cannot move the rook and
queen
are on the same file so instead after
rook 88 we have queen to e1
and now knight captures on g3 we have
queen captures and
now queen to f7 so
it's a very very tricky position but uh
one thing that
you you can notice is that white is
still up upon white has eight pawns
black has only seven points
and should everything get traded off the
board that would be
most likely a a winning game for nipple
so here
rook a to d1 uh and now comes c6
finally that c6 moves a move happens now
the d51 is nicely defended
and f4 now and if you look at the
position now still it's not easy for
white to break through white will of
course try to get some
something happening along maybe the f
file maybe try to get f5 in
but uh black will do everything nice to
allow that so here
knight to c5 attacking the bishop and
rook
h to f1 we have queen to e6 and
now uh again the f5 square is a very uh
nicely defended so here nipple goes for
queen to h3
and he says all right we trade queens
and then uh
you know we just play the same game for
example if the queens get traded off
captures capture so let's say knight
captures on d3
uh c captures uh it's uh well it's uh
maybe playable for black but uh very
very hard to say
white is upon it his position is better
he's going to bring the king to f3
uh probably position the rooks and the b
file maybe double them up
we'll push this pawn all the way up and
uh somewhere make a breakthrough and
then enjoy his extra pawn
but okay after queen to h3 we have rook
to f5
black decides for this very very tricky
idea
where if nepo accepts the rook then g
captures and then black really closes
the pawn structure completely
and it's hard to say if you will be able
to break through the knight and c5
is just just a monster because white
doesn't have a b
pawn or a d pawn to chase it away and
the knight will nicely guard the b7 pawn
so here it's very unlikely that you
would be able to break through
probably you can but not maybe in a
blitz game as these are blitz games
so here instead uh or instead of just
grabbing that after rook to f5
nepo decided to eliminate one of the
defenders of the e4 square he played c
for undermining d5
so here we have knight captures on the
three rook
captures on d3 and now b5 and here you
can still kind of play the game if you
let's say play some like rook d to f8
but it's still going to be very hard
but here b5 was played and now nepo just
played c
captures on b5 c captures on b5 and now
without even pausing the video i know
you guys know what nipple played
but just in case uh you know have at it
uh win the game
uh there there is one move that really
uh eliminates black
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations i'm realizing that
we've removed all the defenders and now
we can finally push it
and that is e4 so congratulations to
everyone who found it
after this was played uh mathman
resigned the game and a very nice game
for a very nice win
a win for yanipanishi so here you cannot
do anything because if you capture with
this pawn then you lose the rook
you can't really move the rook because
then you lose the queen
and other than that there is really not
much you can play here you can
play some weird moves but we very rarely
analyze those
uh so yeah really a nice one and thought
you guys might enjoy this it's very
very easy to play it uh just you know uh
d4
knight c3 bishop f4 and you go after
this spawn and it looks like a barbaric
thing to do but
uh you know you might you might enjoy it
and maybe your opponent
doesn't really know what what to do with
this so you know try it and see what
happens
uh but yeah like i said after e4 and
matman resigned and
uh a wonderful victory for ianni ponishi
so like i said we're gonna be
from you know up until november we're
going to be covering more and more of
jan's games uh if you have any of your
there are your favorites do suggest them
especially if they're very unknown so
we enjoy those the most but we are going
to go uh
through uh some uh some of them and uh
see
what what is in store for magnus and
we're gonna be discussing the world
chess championship match
uh as november new year's uh so yeah
that's the game i hope you guys enjoyed
it
uh i would like to thank austin del rio
rocket al qaeda
justin brockhouse frederick rusek and
akram the pilot for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day